[Music]
hey guys each barrel is the first
official photo sub-game endurance is 1/8
giving us a first look at many of our
favorite characters obviously HB is not
releasing any information about these
photos but there's still plenty of
information we can get out of them most
of the characters are gathering a
mineral or on their way to Winterfell
oh but Cersei who is at the capital
let's start with this photo forest
archaea she's looking up at something or
it's probably a winner fell but she
could also be Minter town a settlement
in the north located just outside of
Winterfell itself during the years long
winter switch hit the region the small
folk of the north came to huddle for
protection in settlements outside the
walls of NFL we have seen many
characters on this location from Tyrion
to Brienne and Podrick
and here Arya might be in winter town
possibly gather information about
people's opinions about Jon and they and
even the dragons appear in the sky the
seem of them probably Panther John and
Danny just before they arrived of NFL I
assume this is them looking at Manor
fell from a distance some believe this
is somewhere beyond the wall
judging from the landscape behind them
remember winter is here and the
nothing's closer to them than ever so it
could be anywhere but my guess is it's
summer clothes from NFL the nurses white
fur dress has been updated with some red
fabric here it emphasized to house
colors or just to differentiate yourself
on the background this photo which was
really separately from the other season
8 photos likely to pick the same scene
between John and Danny but from a
different angle we know that John and
Danny will arrive at Winterfell in the
very first episode of the final season
in a callback to the series very first
episode with Danny and her camp standing
in for King Robert and his company once
John arrives Seminole fell he'll have a
heartbreaking reunion of his family with
sin sorry I'm brain as well as with his
friend Sam and his devil ghost after
reuniting with Saints and Arya and after
presenting Danny to his family and all
the North Lords general also had a brief
moment it's same as well many are
wondering if John's arrival will stand
as a chance for Sam and bran to finally
reveal John his true lineage and the
answer is most likely now even though
brain has been waiting the whole season
to reveal the John the truth I don't
think he'll really touch
their first meeting the reason being too
many people around them
Brennan Sam will likely wait for a
private moment with John rather than
feeling such an important life-changing
information to him in front of everyone
and this scene right there might be the
moment it's the same smiling the way he
only smiles spent Cesar talks to John
and he might be entering John chamber to
have a chat with his best friend when I
think of it say might not even be at the
courtyard of Winterfell when John
arrives as he's probably too deep into
the books to know what's going on
outside so this might just be the scene
where Sam reunites with John John and
Sam will see each other for the very
first time since John was killed and
resurrected say might even be the one to
reveal to John his sure parentage
well Holland and brain could confirm
these same statements to John with some
evidence if John tells them about what
happened to him in the Nights Watch
death and resurrection
it's possible they decided revealing to
John that he's a Targaryen samurai to
also proclaim jhanas were high in the
season 7 premiere show pointing out that
the bogey Lee picked up and began
reading was a book about the long night
while the exact bar she was reading was
about the prophecy of azor Ahai anyways
upon finding out about John Shu
parentage in season 7 which basic
confirms that he is a Song of Ice and
Fire
and upon finding out about John's death
and resurrection the final season it's
quite possible it samuel proclaim Jana's
were high hero that was reborn amid
smoking salt a hero that will build the
flaming sword to stand against the
others and if he falls the world Falls
vetted it's going to be very interesting
to see John's reaction I also believe
that the book about the long night that
Gilley was reading in the season 7
premiere will resurface in the final
season which would likely attempt once
again as brain if he is able to look
back in time but it's time even deeper
into the past to see what exactly
happened the last time the White Walkers
came for the living this is how a
membrane will play a huge role in the
final season as they will help John and
Danny strategize for their fight against
the night king and his army of the Dead
speaking of brain here we seem sitting
before the fire eater contemplating how
to defeat the night king or how to
reveal the truth for John here we see
John standing in Winterfell courtyard
probably after he is reunited with his
family and after the tense meeting
between Danny in all the Starks Varys is
also there and so is Tyrion Lannister
Tyrion stands on the battlements of NFL
wearing a new wintry outfit this is
Tyrion third time visiting Winterfell if
you recall Tyrion visiting
fell twice in the very first season the
first time is part of King Robert's
entourage and then on his way back from
the wall pausing it winter fell on the
return shipped home Tyrion gave bran
plans for a special saddle so that he
can ride even in his crippled state the
first thing I noticed about this photo
is Tyrion suspicious look that he my
opinion gives to John and Danny there in
his jealous and it's not just my guess
it's been confirmed by the season 7
scripts upon being released the official
game of Thrones script shed light on
several contests the details from the
show's seventh season including dierence
real feelings for Danny Game of Thrones
has confirmed what many fans had
suspected by the end of the last season
the Tyrion Lannister is in love with
Dana Targaryen for season six episode 10
the winsome enter the script reads at
one point Dan is staring into the
distance so Tyrion is able to watch her
from a close goddamn she's beautiful
he watches her for a bit too long and
turns away lost in her own thoughts she
doesn't notice that he's flustered
season 7 episode 4 the spoils of war
makes it even more obvious during the
scene where Tyrion watches Jaime putting
himself in mortal danger by charging at
Danny and her dragon drogon the script
says the brother he loves raced towards
this parallel death at the hands of the
Queen Tyrion also loves Twitter Dinklage
an actor who plays Taran hinted at his
character's true feelings for Danny
earlier this year the question was by
deterring have a rather dark and
troubled expression upon realizing that
John and Danny are consummating their
relationship and what was Tyrion
thinking to himself at that very moment
keep it down over there I'm trying to
get some sleep Dinklage jokes but then
he got serious and delivered a rather
thoughtful and detailed answer no it's
complicated
decode says a lot of time material it's
professional and personal obviously he
has feelings for Danny he loves her or
thinks he does she's a inspiring he is
questioning that because he doesn't have
a good track record for falling in love
there's jealousy wrapped up in there and
he loves Jon Snow 232 people he has the
most in common with they're both
Outsiders in their own families who
refuse to follow the path their family
has taken and hopefully for the better
he's wondering how smart of a move John
and Danny getting romantically involved
this because passion and politics don't
mix well he knows the two of them
getting together could be very dangerous
so basically it's a mix of feelings
Tyrion is jealous because he loves Danny
but also worried for her because he
thinks this relationship might not end
well with that being established Game of
Thrones fans have something more
concrete to hold on to and formulating
their theories for the upcoming season
it's not a coincidence that people
behind the series opted 20 on season 7
story with him in the shadows knowing
fully well that John and Danny were
consummating their relationship
his love for Danny knowing that her
faction allies did someone else could
very well push Tyrians loyalty elsewhere
after all we still don't know what he
answers safe fully talked about in the
Chamber's from the camera car away
additionally it's also hinted that Danny
after all might not be who Tyrion wants
to see on the Iron Throne with the
script revealing that he sees Danny as
the same as he sees the Mad King love is
not the only motion Tyrion feels for
Danny
he's also scared of her and fears for
what her role would bring upon the
people of the Seven Kingdoms
especially as Dani burns Randall and eke
entirely alive in Eastwatch inside
Terrence thoughts the script links Danny
to her met father King Aerys Targaryen
Tyrians thoughts are their last best
hope is also her father's daughter
anyways back to the season 8 photos so
John and Danny arrive with their cruise
John introduces Danny to his family and
his many Indians however while there
will be a few moments of a heartbreaking
Iranian between Jon and his family and
friends there will be no time for much
small talk because VFL is already
preparing for the war upon being
informed about the fall of the wall the
next single scene Manor fell is easy too
soon to be done having an urgent meeting
with majority of the north Lords and his
allies to the Great Hall in order to
discuss their strategy and defenses
which brings us to next for us the ones
from the great meeting in Mina fell
almost all of the main characters will
be there and we've got to see dawa sense
a Danian Brienne that was listens
carefully as he states with a mental
radiance solid soldier behind him
judging by the look of Davos he might
even be looking at lady Melisandre
returning to Winterfell which is only a
matter of time until she does although
that just the possibility that was could
also be looking at pretty much anyone
Brienne's loco so seems intense and when
you look deeper into it it also seems as
if she's afraid for the person she loves
could she be looking at Jaime Lannister
has he already arrived at Winterfell the
last time he saw Jamie he finally left
Cersei and he was wearing the same armor
on his way out of King's Landing
now he's also beard in the northern
armor shoulder pads here putos for this
guys are combat or you could even
possibly mean that by this time he's
already pledged to house dark and those
shoulder pads that look exactly like
Rob's are given to him by the Starks I
believe Jamie Ximena fell here and
Brienne is worried for howdini Targaryen
the person he tried to kill and brain
stark also the person he tried to kill
they react to it then they are Sen John
Snow invited Lannisters to come to
support a living in the Moors to come
and even though Cersei play them Jaime
on the other hand honor his pledge
meaning that no harm would John nor
Danny do to him
nor would they allow anyone else to do
so Tyrion Umbreon will be happy and
proud that Jaime is honor his pledge and
will vouch for him if any trouble shall
find him at Winterfell
of course Jamie's the most important
reunion is the one with brain stark the
kid he tried to kill to keep him from
reporting what he just witnessed they
reported were a result of Jaime Cersei
and all their children being executed
fortunately Brent survived but his lost
ability to walk the question we all have
regarding this really nice hobble brain
react first glance would assume that
brain would react angrily since that's
the man who almost killed in the last
time they saw each other but it will
most likely not be the case rather than
Stannis ting Jaime to death bran will in
my opinion revealed to everyone the real
truth behind a meze so-called betrayal
eridanus father the Mad King probably
when someone insults Jaime a Kingslayer
brain Villareal that Jaime should not be
mocked and called the Kingslayer rather
the hero and the savior of the city of
King's Landing
Jaime killed Matt King because he could
now let him burn hundreds of thousands
of innocent people so seemingly an
intense reunion with something code
namely James that feel likely happened
just the opposite Jaime in his great
deeds he'll finally get the recognition
he and his act against the Mad King
deserve not the traitor another
Kingslayer
but the hero and the savior of King's
Landing in its people last but not least
we have a great up close look at search
say on the aren't mound we get to see
one of sources new gowns since season
eight it looks like she's added some
golden armor to her ensemble this photo
is likely from the same scene with this
release you can expect the first
official trailer to drop anytime now let
me know your opinion about these photos
in the comment section down below
and as always I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and they
hope to see you in the next one peace